hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
technical terms of the stoic logic and
remember that for stowage logic doesn't
just mean formal logic as we think about
it today and teach about it today but
also epistemology really the entire
range of how we put our thoughts
together how we you know measure things
how we attain the truth all that fits
under the stoic logic so there is this
term that gets translated in english as
preconceptions or general ideas or
general conceptions and there isn't any
really great way of rendering it the
greek is prolate so preconception is
probably the closest the reason why
people are saying general conceptions is
because they are indeed of great
generality as we'll see so pro basis
it's coming from the term bombing which
which can be you know translated as to
stretch one's hand outta tune to grasp
to reach for to grip and pierogi nose is
for you know so your think of these as
ways in which to be very metaphorical
but think about these as ways and where
we reach our mind out to things and grip
onto them you know when we say we wrap
our mind around some sort of state of
affairs or something a person is trying
to convey to us it's rather complex and
money we're using preconceptions as a
matter of fact according to the Stoics
and epictetus we can't help but use
preconceptions all the time so again
quite a bit written here we're going to
come back to some of them but I want to
go through this this passage coming from
chapter 22 of what one he says
preconceptions are common to all people
and one preconception does not
contradict another or war against it for
whom Manos does not assume that the good
is profitable and something to be chosen
and that in every circumstance we want
to seek and pursue it who among us does
not assume that righteousness is
beautiful and becoming so we're then
this contradiction arise and so he says
preconceptions actually agree in
themselves although we may have kind of
money and only implicit grasp upon them
so what are we going to apply them to
specific cases that we run into all
sorts of difficulties and people come to
different conclusions about the same
object that same action the same idea
and you know using the preconceptions
they arrive at things that seem to
contradict each other especially don't
just seem to do so he says one example
that person acted nobly or well you know
they did a good thing because their
their action was brave right there
implying some general conception of
bravery which they think to be a good
thing the other person says that's not
brave at all so you're saying that
doesn't apply to this they're not saying
that bravery is a bad thing although
perhaps they can have a district
reamonn about that as well we do go into
that sort of thing perhaps you know
their their understanding and how the
preconceptions connect with each other
is a little bit screwed up but this
person is actually contesting and saying
that action was foolhardy that's an act
of madness that's a bad thing so they
they end up in a sort of clash in
contradiction with each other and you
can say well look we fed the same data
into these two processors why didn't
they spit out the same answer oh because
human beings are pretty messy and
complicated in that way so on this
affects cultures he says then summarizes
the conflict of metals with each other
this is the conflict between for example
Jews and Syrians and Egyptians and
Romans not over the question whether
holiness should be put before everything
else and should be pursued in all
circumstances but whether the particular
activating swine's flesh is holy or
unholy so cultural ways of understanding
these these general ideas these these
general valuations of things can come
into contradiction with each other quite
easily going a little bit further he has
a great example with Agamemnon and
Achilles e says this is the case of the
conflict between Agamemnon and Achilles
in the Iliad at the start right come
some of them before us what do you say I
have done why not dad to be done which
is proper and that which is Noble
Agamemnon says yeah I can get behind
that because he has that preconception
and then Achilles well what do you say
Achilles do you not agree that what is
noble ought to be done Kelly says yeah
that's why I'm all about they says all
right apply your preconceptions to the
particular cases that big kisses that's
where the conflict starts and if you
read the beginning of the Iliad you will
see a whole discussion and argument
going on in which both of them are
pressing their either side both of them
according to epictetus are using
preconceptions but they are applying
them differently to the same case and
winding up with different conclusion
and conclusions that actually are going
to have a fateful consequence so he goes
on a little bit more and he says you
know let's let's think about this here
we go it is my nature to look out for my
own interest if it's in my interest you
have a farm it's in my interest to take
it away from my neighbor if it is my
interest at a cloak it is also my
interest to steal it from a bath this is
the source of wars seditions charities
and plots and again how shall I be able
to maintain my mind duty towards towards
the gods you know what do I have to do
with these and so you know why do people
arrive at these sort of conclusions well
there's something going on in the
juncture between the preconceptions and
how they end up getting applied there's
something going astray there it is a
good thing to look out for ourselves is
it a good thing to look out for
ourselves to the exclusion of fellow
feeling towards other human beings and
respecting their rights no but that's a
case where say one preconception seems
to contradict another you know I should
do what's good for me I should also
respect other people's rights when you
actually look at it people will say well
I'm not really disrespecting their
rights maybe they had it coming to them
they'll have all sorts of dodges when we
get to the level of the specific cases
now what else do we need to say about
this epictetus you notice of the very
very beginning of this he says that
these are general these are common to
human beings are coining there or spread
it across everything and they don't
fight against they don't mind I and
greet each other they don't conflict
with talking translators they don't
concert
each other there it's not even that they
don't contradict each other they don't
enter into conflict is probably the best
way to translate that so why do we have
conflicts about this well because we are
poorly educated we have not been trained
well to use our preconceptions it's not
a sort of automatic process where we
just have innate ideas and we just sort
of you know apply them schematically to
everything and things go great there's a
lot of ways in which things can go off
the rails including perhaps the bad
example of other people and how they
using these preconceptions so he goes on
and with this in that chapter what does
it mean to be getting an education it
means to be learning how to apply the
natural preconceptions to particular
cases so that's one part of it each to
the other in conformity with nature
that's one key part of it nature and by
nature we don't mean you know the same
nature that natural scientists today
mean so you know just put that in
suspense for the time being with stoics
mean by nature is something a bit
different in a little bit more
substantive hang our preconceptions and
our application of them in accordance
with nature is is a precondition to
getting things right once we get to the
level of particulars and particulars are
where we have to make our decisions
particulars are the sort of things that
can you know compro yeah that combines
to form our lives are individualized in
our mutual life together so he says we
also need to be able to make the
distinction some things or under our
control others are not including world
purpose in the acts of moral purpose
right so when we're thinking about where
we're going to place the good and the
bad do we place it in things that aren't
really under our jurisdiction so to
speak like this this is not the locus of
the good
it were the bad for me whether this tie
matches this shirt is really a historic
perspective pretty unimportant thing
it's so unimportant that we could call
it an indifferent Nadia fora right
whether I work to meet the expectations
of those who I'm trying to provide some
sort of goodnick for that isn't my my
purpose right and so if we don't know
how to apply these basic ideas well
we're going to run into a lot of lot of
problems and an education from the
student perspective is precisely
learning how to make sense of those
sorts of things we see this again when
we turn each chapter 17 a book to which
also talks about preconceptions he said
this is about how we we want to apply
them to particulars he says what is the
first business of one who practices
philosophy to get rid of thinking that
one knows where it's impossible to get a
man to begin to learn that which he
thinks he knows however as we go to the
Philosopher's we all babble hurly-burly
about what ought to be done and what
what not good and evil fair and foul and
all these grounds assign praise and
blame centric reprehend passing judgment
and discriminating between them what are
we doing there we are using our
preconceptions that we have and we're
like in a little playground right that's
what people think philosophy classes are
just playing on the players my ideas
expressed myself and all that when
really you know epictetus he says why do
we go there why did what did we go to
the Philosopher's port to learn what we
do don't think we know and what is that
general principles now does that mean
that we didn't have general principles
before we walk in the door no we have
them but we don't have them in the way
that we need to or ought to have them he
says some of us want to learn of the
Philosopher's are saying thinking it's
going to be you know witty and shrewd
but you know what we need to do is look
at
what our preconceptions are and how
these philosophers can help us
straighten them out he goes on he says
who among us has not upon his lips the
words good and evil advantageous and
disadvantageous for who among us doesn't
added a preconceived idea of each of
these terms here's the key very well is
it fitted into a system has it been
correlated with all the other
preconceptions so that it can be applied
or rather in its applications to the
whole world and to ourselves and other
people that's the key thing that we're
looking for has it been systematized and
made complete these are you might say
outlines they are not in themselves
complete from the start we have to work
on them to make them complete and we do
that again applying them to particular
cases too many many particular cases so
he says is it fitted into a system and
complete prove that it is how shall I
prove it good question there right apply
you properly to specific facts to start
with for example Plato classifies
definitions under the preconception be
useful but you classify them under that
of the useless is it possible then for
both of you to be right how can that be
does not one man apply as preconceived
idea that good to the fact of wealth
another does not another to pleasure
another that health indeed to sum up the
whole matter if all of us who have these
terms on our lips possess no mere empty
knowledge of each one severally and do
not need to devote any pains to the
systematic arrangement the article seen
in in Greek Lee this sort of setting
straight in a systematic way of these
then why do we disagree why do we fight
why do we blame one another so the the
promise here the stomachs are making is
that if we do work on an education an
education doesn't just me
reading a lot more us and talking cool
stoic stuff it means actually applying
it and I'm you know thinking about it
and seeing through experiential practice
how this work if we do that then we are
going to be able to apply these right
and we are still going to end up in
conflict with other people but we're
going to get in conflict with other
people now just because we're all at sea
and applying things in an inconsistent
haphazard leg but because we're actually
applying them right and they're applying
them in those cases wrong so I'm just
having preconceptions by itself does not
guarantee that we're automatically going
to go right you have a lot of work to do
with these but it's helpful to have this
sort of thing identified so that we can
then turn to see well can we in fact
systematize make insistence our
preconceptions